3 semaines après le début de la guerre
entre Israël et le mouvement palestinien
hamass Gaza est coupé du monde cette
phrase est extraite d'une dépêche AFP du
27 octobre on y liit bien la guerre
contre le mouvement palestinien àamass
en fait cette dépêche n'est que le
reflet des consignes donné par la
direction de l'agence dans une note
interne on y lit notamment que pour
décrire le Hamas il faut parler je cite
de combattants du Hamas et non
d'islamiste du Hamas tandis que le
qualificatif terroriste est tout
simplement à proscrire le directeur de
l'information expliquant que ce mot a
tout bonnement perdu son sens pourtant
il n'y a pas si longtemps lafp employait
ce mot de terroriste pour décrire les
exactions de daesh d'al-qïda les
assassinats de Boko Haram l'attentat
contre Charlie Hebdo mais que s'est-il
passé depuis décapiter des bébés
éventrer des femmes enceintes brûler des
êtres humains kidnapper violer ce n'est
pas du terrorisme et bien non
apparemment pour lafp lafp est l'une des
trois grandes agences mondiales la seule
européenne ses abonnés sont les médias
français mais aussi étrangers les
entreprises les institutions son pouvoir
d'influence est donc énorme considérable
j'ai été journaliste près de 40 ans
pendant de longues années la FP c'était
la Bible de l'information mais ce
tempslà est révolu alors madame la
ministre l'état s'apprête à verser 141
millions d'euros à lafp budget en hausse
de 5 % au titre écoutez bien de sa
mission d'intérêt général alors madame
la ministre comment comptez-vous réagir
quand sur le site de votre ministère il
est écrit que la FP est la seule agence
mondiale qui produise de l'information
originale complète objective et digne de
confiance je
vousci la parole est
ministre de la
Culture madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Bard un premier appel pour paraphraser
ce que disait ma collègue Laurence Bou
la France a très clairement défini le
Hamas comme un groupe terroriste ainsi
que l'Union européenne et un très grand
nombre de
pays autre rappel important si le
ministère de
Laure à l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
si le ministère de la Culture finance en
partie lafp lafp n'est pas une agence
gouvernementale c'est une agence de
presse indépendante et à l'instar des
agences Reuters ou Associated Press
laafp a expliqué que depuis plus de 20
ans ils ont pris cette consigne de ne
pas utiliser le mot terrorisme pour s'en
tenir aux faits mais il me semble que
les faits
décrits dans le cas des attaques
barbares du Hamas sont suffisamment
claires pour que tout le monde comprenne
qu'il s'agit d'actes terroristes les
médias qui rédigent des articles à
partir des dépêches de la FP utilise
d'ailleurs très souvent s'il vous plaît
on écouteot
terroriste dans le contexte de dans le
contexte de gravité est-ce que vous
pouvez m'écouter jusqu'au bout vous
plaît dans le contexte de gravité que
nous vivons et je le dis avec d'autant
plus d'émotion en présence de famillees
d'otage retenu expation laborieuse s'il
vous plaît depuis le 7 octobre où le
Hamas a franchi toutes les lignes rouges
imaginables avec cette barbarie et cette
cruauté
inqualifiable je peux comprendre que le
choix de ne pas utiliser ce mot de
terrorisme puiss susciter des remous des
incompréhensions des indignations mais
monsieur le député Ballard le
gouvernement n'écrit pas les dépêche de
laafp et ne corrige pas les dépêches de
laafp la presse est indépendante dans
notre pays monsieur le député
B ce qui m'a choqué pour ma part puisque
vous me demandez mon avis c'est la
mention de l'exemple de Nelson Mandela
dans un des communiqués d'explication de
l'fp je pense qu'on peut pas laisser
penser qu'on met sur le même plan le
Hamas et Nelson Mandela j'aurais aimé
que la mesure cette responsabilité toute
particulière merci beaucoup madame la
ministre